what's going on guys in this video i'm
gonna explain the full backstory of
hawks
who is currently the number two hero in
the world of my here academia
this character was first introduced to
someone who quickly rose through the
ranks of your society
but unlike the previous number two hero
who was obsessed with being the
strongest horse could not have had a
more different outlook on life
he outright stated that he would have
preferred to have been ranked lower in
the chart so he could have more freedom
to do what he wants
and envisioned a world in which heroes
would have a ton of free time to relax
his reason for thinking this way becomes
clearer when we look into his backstory
so this video will cover everything
there is to know about hawkes from his
early childhood all the way up until his
first appearance in the anime
before we begin though don't forget to
sub for more my academia videos like
this
and remember that my new discord server
is now open for anyone to join
when we talk about my hero academia as
well as a bunch of other series
for the anime only's watching there will
be spoilers ahead for hawks's backstory
specifically
um so if you'd rather wait till season
six or potentially season seven of the
anime then pause the video now
okay so to begin hawks's real name is
keigo takami
and he was born in the outskirts of
fukuoka this city is located on the
island of kyushu
and in the real world fukuoka has a
baseball team literally named the hawks
which i don't think is a coincidence in
his childhood hawks's father was a
low-level villain who we only know as
takami and he had been on the run from
the law
after killing a guy over some pocket
change takami was also a known thief
but he managed to evade the authorities
thanks to the help of tomi
who is hawks's mother tomi had a quirk
that gave her a pair of levitating
eyeballs
presumably allowing her to view things
from a distance
over the years takami relied on tomi's
quirk to keep themselves hidden
and find new criminal opportunities at
some point tomi accidentally got
pregnant
giving birth to hawks in this run-down
shack on the outskirts of the city
the shack itself was completely filthy
with garbage scattered all across the
floor
and as you can tell hawks did not have a
great time growing up here
takami was constantly paranoid that
people were looking for him so hawks was
not allowed to leave the house because
takami thought his son might rat him out
as a result he spent a ton of time
indoors as a kid and on one occasion his
mother secretly took him out
so he would stop whining the two of them
went to a grocery store
where tomi purchased an endeavor doll
for her son because the endeavor toy was
six times cheaper than the almighty one
in the panel we can see the endeavor
dolls are on sale which just shows that
you know he was never really near
almight's level of popularity
but at the same time the doll was
something that hawks treasured a lot
he could be seen carrying it around all
the time not to mention that during his
bad days
he would hug the doll for comfort i'll
talk about this more very soon
but when hawk's mother purchased this
toy she said to him that she hopes he
could one day grow up to be as strong as
endeavour
anyway back home hawks's father would
physically attack his son for trivial
reasons
despite the fact that he was a quiet
child who never really did anything
wrong
hawks endured the abuse in the hope that
he could make it out and not end up like
his parents
but at this stage he still didn't have
the desire to become a hero
in his words the only time he ever saw
heroes was on the tv
so the idea of them was more of a
fantasy than a reality
as a poor child living on the outskirts
of a city heroes didn't connect to his
everyday life
so it's definitely understandable that
he would think this way on one fateful
day
takami was finally arrested by the
authorities after stealing a car
and the person who caught hoax's father
was none other than endeavour himself
with this one action pro heroes finally
became real in his mind
and the fact that it was endeavor made
it even sweeter because obviously
he already had the endeavor plushie with
his father out of the picture
hawks's life instantly began to change
although at the beginning it wasn't so
great
his mother was afraid that she'd get
arrested for helping takami all those
years
so both heron hawks left the family
shack that same day
the problem was that tomi didn't have
the necessary skills to raise a child in
regular society
so the two ended up living on the
streets with no money
hawks's only possession was his endeavor
plushie and the clothes on his back
so he suggested that they go to the
police instead his mother taunted him
for not putting his wings to good use
as she wanted him to utilize his quirk
to get them some money
if hawks wanted to he definitely could
have used his powers for theft i mean
it's almost perfect for that
but i feel like his idolization of
endeavor meant that he wanted to do
things the right way
following this there was one day in
which hawks went out by himself
probably to collect supplies as we see
he has a little bag there
and as he was walking by there was a
high-speed car accident
his feathers must have tingled in the
same way they did before and he
proceeded to save
every single last person this panel of
his feathers pulling people away from
the wreckage
is quite reminiscent of what happened
during the pro hero arc but for hawks to
have done
all of this as an untrained little kid
yeah that's pretty incredible
after the incident he immediately left
so no one actually knew who he was
but someone from the public safety
commission heard about what happened
they couldn't believe that someone so
young performed this act of heroism and
a search was launched to find this
wander child as quickly as possible
tomi and hawks were then approached by
two agents from the safety commission
with tomi being made an offer she
couldn't refuse in exchange for handing
her son
over she would get indefinite financial
support and her connection to takami
would be erased
that meant she would not get in any
trouble for the crimes she helped takami
commit
plus she would be able to start a new
life with all the cash needless to say
hawkes was separated from tomi in that
moment
and going forward the safety commission
made him give up his name
the name keigo takami was a race and the
public safety commission had the unique
opportunity
to mold this child into a special hero
who had no ties to anyone
before entering the special hero
training program they informed hawks
that the training would be brutal
but the idea of becoming someone like
endeavour is what spurred him on to take
the opportunity
this ties into what hawks's mother had
said to him when they got the doll in
the first place
for at least the next decade hawkes
would learn a bunch of different skill
sets from the training program
with one of the drills being shown in
the post credits during season 4.
in this exercise we can see that hawks
was blindfolded and made to use the
vibrations from his
feathers to visualize his surroundings
that training clearly paid off
but still it must have been really
grueling for a young child later in the
manga
he reveals that he had interpersonal
skills drilled into him from a young age
which is something that helps him get
information out of people and build new
relationships
at the age of 18 hawks finally finished
his training and became a professional
hero with his own agency
this in itself is very unusual as most
new heroes work as sidekicks after
graduation
and then if they're popular enough
they'll go independent later on
starting an agency at the age the hawks
did is just not something you see very
often
but the madness didn't end there as
later that same year he was ranked in
the top 10 heroes
that made him the first ever person to
achieve top 10 status
as a teenager even faster than his idol
endeavor
flash forward a few years and hawks was
interested in learning more about the
league of villains after they attached
ua
so he observed the kiss from class 1a
during the sports festival his goal was
to take one of these students on an
internship so he could use those
communication skills to get some
information out of them
his original target was to get shoto
todoroki but he ended up going for
tokiyami instead
as they're both birds however tokyomi
felt like he didn't learn anything
during this internship
because hawkes was too fast for him to
keep up with and whenever they did have
time to chat
all hawks would ask him about was the
usj attack after the battling camino
between all for one and almight
hawkes was approached by the public
safety commission with a mission that
only he was capable of doing
on the orders of the head of the
commission hawks was told to infiltrate
the league of villains and become a
double agent
his task was to pretend he aligned with
the league's goals therefore joining the
organization
and passing back valuable information to
the heroes that could be used to take
the villains down he had no choice but
to accept the mission
as his training and his current
circumstance at that time meant that he
was the only person that could pull this
off
as a result he then got in contact with
derby from the league of villains with
the two of them reaching a verbal
agreement
darby said he wanted to test the
fighting power of a nomu and arts hawks
to bring someone who was kind of strong
to a specified location derby would
later go back on this agreement
and he changed the location and the date
of the test to when hawkes and endeavour
were together
the high end was never meant to attack
at this location
but you know darby's a villain so he's
gonna do shady things
one last thing to mention before the pro
hero arc tokyomi was invited back to
hawke's agency for a work study
he did this work study at the same time
that deku was working with sir naitai
and it turned out to be a lot more
productive than tokyomi's previous
internship
this time around tokyoyami had massively
improved so much so that he was kind of
able to keep up with hawke's speed
and as a reward horts gave him an
important lesson we'll be seeing this
interaction play out in season 5
but basically hawks's advice allowed
tokyami to unlock a new super move
which we see him use during the joint
training arc let me know in the comments
down below what you think of hawks's
backstory
i mean one thing i would say is that
it's surprising the amount of characters
in this series
who just have terrible fathers or
fathers who never show up like it is
quite incredible the amount
don't forget to like and subscribe as it
does help out the channel and until the
next one
peace out